hi this is pressure Locker let's discuss
a math problem from the movie die hard
with the Vengeance samuel l.jackson and
bruce willis have to solve a puzzle to
the Sarma bomb they need from a three
and five gallon jug to fill exactly four
gallons of water how can you do this if
you want to think about the problem you
can pause the video right now otherwise
you can keep listening to hear the
solution we'll start out by filling the
five gallon jug entirely with water
it'll be useful to keep track of the
amount of water that's in each jug
now what we'll do is transfer over water
from the five gallon jug until it fills
a three gallon jug since we're removing
three gallons from the five gallon jug
that'll leave exactly two gallons in
there now we pour out the water from the
three gallon jug and then we transfer
over the two gallons between the jugs we
once again fill up the five gallon jug
and now we can get to four yellen's what
we do is we pour out water from the five
gallon jug until it fills up the three
gallon jug
this will remove one gallon from the
five gallon jug leaving exactly four
gallons as a mathematical aside this
rail corresponds to an equation of 3x
plus 5y equals four and solving it for
integer solutions more generally we can
solve equations ax plus B y equal C and
look for integer solutions in x and y
these are known as linear Diophantine
equations and they've been solved in
fact a solution exists if and only if C
is a multiple the greatest common
divisor of a and B please subscribe to
my channel you can support me on patreon
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on Twitter at pressure Walker
and get my books at Amazon